[Music]
a few days ago top gun maverick the late
sequel to the classic film top gun was
finally released in cinemas after almost
36 years following a total of five
postponements of the release date the
blockbuster was a huge success at the
box office which must have come as a
surprise to some people in fact top gun
maverick even bad pirates of the
caribbean at worlds and as the most
successful film ever released in the us
over the memorial day weekend critics
and fans are also showering the movie
with praise which is why the question of
another sequel is slowly but surely
being raised producer jerry bruckheimer
who was already involved in the first
movie in the same position recently
spoke to deadline about plans for a
potential top count 3. according to the
report there were no immediate plans for
third film but they would continue to
ride the wave of success so given the
gigantic hit it is almost safe to assume
that we will see maverick at his
favorite adrenaline fuel activity once
more we can only hope that this time it
won't take another 36 years
it is almost unthinkable that just a few
years ago there was talk of an indiana
jones film without harrison ford after
all kinds of problems such as a shoulder
injury of the 79 year old leading actor
fans are now even more pleased that
director james mangal published their
first image it shows indiana jones
himself in a dark cave walking across a
bridge in dim light at first sight you
can hardly see any difference to earlier
movies even if harrison ford and thus
his film character indiana jones have
aged noticeably ford also talked about
the movie in the course of a surprise
appearance at the star wars celebration
he said he was very proud of the new
installment and held out the prospect of
wrapping up filming in the near future
he also spoke highly of the
participation of kathleen kennedy and
james mangle both of whom he said he had
a wonderful experience with coaster mats
mickelson was also full of praise for
harrison ford who is said to have given
his superb performance at nearly 80
years of age aside from that we can
expect a true old school movie we're
looking forward to the upcoming indiana
jones 5 which will be released on june
30th 2023
after a long waiting period the third
season of the mandalorian will finally
be released on disney plus in february
2023 as producer jen favreau announced
at the star wars celebration this series
is complete and currently in
post-production while his colleague dave
filoni keeps working on ahsoka favreau
himself is already slowly but surely
devoting himself to the fourth season of
the mandalorian in the newly shown
trailer we see the armor as well as the
helmetless mandalorian who's about to
clear his name the latter eventually
travels to mandalore along with grogu
where he is greeted by the heiress bo
katan whether she will end up helping
him in his endeavor or what else
mandalore has to offer is sadly left
unknown either way din jardin will have
to face moff gideon again as you can
suspect from the star destroyer shown in
the trailer in addition to the ongoing
series lead actor pedro pascal talked
about further plans for the mandalorian
in an interview with variety this
included the fact that pascal's big
dream would be to play the mandalorian
not only on disney plus but also on the
big screen in the future however he did
emphasize that this is only a dream of
his and that to his knowledge a movie is
not officially being planned he would
nonetheless be happy about the
mandalorian cinematic experience
sometime in the future we are excited to
find out what will happen next with the
mandalorian it is at least certain that
the third season will be released on
disney plus on february 23rd 2023
last week the star wars celebration was
held in anaheim california the now 14th
edition of the world's largest star wars
fan gathering was actually supposed to
take place in 2020 but was then
postponed due to the pandemic among the
countless announcements was the new
tales of the jedi series which had long
been the subject of many rumors for
several weeks now more precise
information is available it is known
already that a total of six episodes
will be produced likewise revealed are a
couple of featured characters among them
are count doku meswindu ahsoka anakin
skywalker and qui-gon jin the latter was
played by liam neeson in episode 1 and
as we are now aware he will also be
dubbing the jedi master the series is
conceived as an anthology this means
that we will see the aforementioned jedi
in a variety of stories that are not
necessarily related with three episodes
each the focus will be on a sokatanu on
the one side and count doku on the other
especially the doku episodes are
expected to be quite intense since they
will deal with a bloody development of
the former jedi master into a disciple
of dobbed sidious at least that's what
lucasfilm executive producer dave filoni
implied plus the three episodes with
ahsoka at the center will cover almost
her entire life visitors to the star
wars celebration got their first sneak
peek as lucasfilm screened the very
first episode where ahsoka is still a
baby besides all the information at the
first episode there was also a first
trailer to the delight of many fans one
character is still a mystery because
according to eyewitness reports somebody
can be seen from behind in one of the
scenes which is probably yellow based on
the long hair anyways we are eager for
more news and are really looking forward
to tales of the jedi as the series is
scheduled to be released on disney plus
this fall
between 2012 and 2015 lionsgate achieved
great success with a four-part film
series the hunger games this was
followed last year by the announcement
of a prequel titled the hunger games the
ballot of songbirds and snakes while the
original four movies were based on the
first three volumes of susan collins
novels the upcoming movie built on the
fourth volume which was also released as
a prequel in may 2020 so far it was
known that newcomer tom blyth will play
the infamous villain coriolis snow now
the people in charge also seem to have
found a female leading actress the tank
is of 21 year old rachel zegler who is
best known for her golden globe
award-winning role as maria vazquez in
west side story she stars as lucy gray
baird from district 12 who ends up as a
tribute in the 10th hunger games her
mentor is the aforementioned cory lannis
who seems extremely skeptical at first
but is then won over by lucy's iron will
it'll definitely be interesting to see
how well the ballad of songbirds and
snakes will be received by audiences
after a gap of quite a few years the
release date is set for november 17 2023
sonic the hedgehog 2 is currently still
running in many movie theaters and is
regarded as an acceptable but also not
overly great sequel with worldwide
revenues of around 385 million us
dollars the box office takings are
nevertheless positive and there already
seem to be plans for a third part this
was recently revealed by the two
screenwriters pat casey and josh miller
in a q a session there they spoke about
the fact that they are still in a very
early stage of production not really
knowing which direction they will go
with another sequel the focus of
attention is currently the search of a
voice actor for the character that was
teased and at the end of sonic the
hedgehog 2. it's expected to be a high
profile hollywood star as was the case
with knuckles and idris elba more
details are not known so far at present
those responsible are aiming for release
date in 2024 but we will of course keep
you up to date with further information
playstation fans will hardly have failed
to notice the release of horizon
forbidden west earlier this year the
sequel to horizon zero dawn which was
released in 2017 met just about all of
the fans expectations the story of both
the games takes place about 1 000 years
in the future and deals with the past
downfall of human civilization as we
know it those who are still alive join
together in comparatively small tribes
to stand their ground against the enemy
the foe consists of gigantic machinery
that has largely wiped out mankind and
is very reminiscent of prehistoric
dinosaurs the plot centers around young
ally who not only has to deal with the
machines but also resolve old enmities
between the tribes apart from the
storyline around alloy's personal
history the huge and jaw-dropping world
stands out in both video games as
comicbook.com reports netflix recently
secured the rights for a serious
adaption however it is still unclear in
what direction the series will go in
other words whether it will be strongly
based on the original game or whether it
will pursue a completely different
approach in the existing world in terms
of game adaptions it won't stop at a
horizon zero dawn series because a gran
turismo movie is also in the works sony
announced this at its recent 2022
business segment briefings at the
present time it seems to be the heyday
of video game adaptions anyway as we can
still look forward to the last of us
twisted metal and the recently announced
god of war series by amazon as well as
the movie adaption of ghost of tsushima
that's plenty of content for the tv
screen in our opinion which adaption are
you most excited for and can you think
of any other movie and serious adaptions
of games that haven't been announced yet
feel welcome to let us know in the
comments
that's it for the latest news from the
world of series and films if you haven't
seen the new pinocchio trailer with dom
hangs this week we strongly suggest to
do so apart from that you can find
another movie preview on a channel and
this time the focus is on ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania afterwards you
will definitely know about all the new
developments of the mcu movie
[Music]
you